like what's the are we in the past like
10 years how many good horror movies we
had like two right like we had like um
what's good ones Define okay here's the
thing I genuinely don't know how I would
Define a good horror movie I also don't
watch horror so this has come from a guy
who doesn't watch horror movie judging
yeah yeah
what was the one that came out that was
really [__] good like five six years
ago um they had like a really good
budget [__] for what it's called
video games now
um uh I've I personally liked hereditary
that was the one hereditary yeah yeah
it's pretty good uh yeah I hated that
that [__] me up
right yeah yeah it [__] me up but at
least what I appreciate about hereditary
and just Aries to films in general like
also Midsummer as well was like an
awesome [__] noise yeah I watched
Midsummer but it's like I liked it
because it's like yes it's scary but
it's also just [__] weird yeah and
it's like a trip of a movie yeah and
it's like the way that like they scare
in in those movies especially is like I
love that he doesn't rely on jump scares
like in hereditary maybe there's like
two jump scares at most that I can
remember but like those aren't the
scariest moments of the movie like the
scariest moments are the really quiet
moments of the movie I I couldn't finish
that movie actually well I I finished
it's probably better because the last 10
minutes were [__] weird yeah I I
finished Midsummer that was still like
unnerving and like scary but you know it
didn't [__] me up I remember there was
this one scene in uh hereditary it
happened like pretty early on but uh
yeah yeah I mean without spoiling
exactly what happens there was there was
a scene involving a mother that was just
screaming and crying oh yeah and that
was like such a guttural scream I lit it
it kind of like induced in me PTSD that
I guess I didn't even know I had because
I've I've never experienced what the
mother is
but it was like no that was it is to the
point where I was like this is like too
well acted yeah well I feel like I I was
so good in that yeah she was she was she
was so good she was so good that I
couldn't finish it I was like this this
is getting to a point of real to the
point where I'm like I feel like I'm
seeing something I shouldn't be seeing
now
what is that movie about so dude because
I saw the memes of like everyone
blindfolded because it was crazy because
it was just like blue I can't even
[__] blink bringing this [__]
movie out but this was like a like a
[__] big horror film yeah uh did you
watch it I didn't watch oh my God is
this okay again this is like a
four-year-old memory of me explaining a
movie I didn't really like that much so
like there was just a monster that came
I can't remember why and it would only
kill you if you like looked at it
oh
um so it's the opposite of the Weeping
Angels yeah yes sir yeah and then like I
guess throughout the movie obviously
people look at it and I guess people go
crazy and they're like I have to look at
it and then and then all I have in
memory now is like okay one it was it
was it was terrible yeah yeah and uh
everyone doing the Stupid Bird Box
challenge afterwards which is people
just walking around blindfolded which is
just like okay you mean being blind is a
challenge now
all right okay blind people could see
this yeah okay yeah and then I remember
there was another thing where like so in
the movie you never see the uh the thing
that's killing everyone you never see it
yeah and then afterwards I don't know if
it was like a joke or what they were
like hey this is what it was actually
gonna look like and it looked like ass
it was like the shittiest looking thing
there's a there's another movie with a
similar premise where like the thing
that's killing everyone uh you know
can't be seen do you guys watch The
Happening oh
wait what's that one it's the [__]
movie where it's like uh who who was in
that movie again I think it was Mark
Wahlberg I think was that the enlight
Shyamalan movie I think oh was it I
don't remember what's Eminem but like I
only watched like the first third of
them okay so [__] but basically the the
general promise from what I can remember
is like there's this thing like the next
40 minutes is three dudes who don't
watch horror
yeah it's like it's like this movie
where like uh Mark Wahlberg is like
people are just like mysteriously dying
from this phenomena that no one can see
and they call it the happening yeah they
just like all these people are dying
what what's happening and then Mark
Wahlberg [__] runs around trying to
figure it out and again I don't know how
it ends yeah it was like mean to [__]
because it was so bad but um oh I
remember this yeah yeah yeah I have not
just seen it I know the entire plot of
that film just for people complaining
about it actually have you seen have you
seen unfriended yes
I want to get unfriended is where
there's like I believe I don't can't
remember if it's Zoom or if this was
before okay okay
I'm like who is it on the call
it's so bad it's like everything that I
think is like like it's like the
opposite of everything British yeah yeah
yeah and it's just a bunch it's just
like a ghost killing people on Skype and
it's just like can they hang up no you
cannot hang up your Skype call for some
reason and they just all die one by one
uh okay I'm gonna like I'm okay out of
the horror movies that I've seen with
Sydney I'm gonna try and recommend some
good ones but again again I know what
counts as a good horror movie but these
ones these are ones that I found was
interesting uh so one that was that I
found pretty interesting pretty recently
I don't even know if it counts as a
horror movie it's more like a horror
satire uh it's called the menu oh yeah
yeah have you seen that one uh I have
yeah it's really good yeah yeah that
that was so rough no not rough finds um
what the [__] is there are fines Ralph
director no the main actor the British
guy I can't remember the one featuring
the girl from Queen's game yeah the the
girl from Queensland that's the one
that's the one so I love how we
collectively know that yeah so basically
fines right am I crazy yeah thank God
he's the girl so basically it's kind of
like a horror satire of the whole fine
dining kind of culture it's basically
like what mealing yeah it's basically
Battle Royale but like in a setting of
what Malin sees in her Mind's Eye yeah
you know yeah genuinely yeah Google
review is trying to kill each other yeah
yeah imagine if you saw the world the
way Millions yeah yeah yeah that's
that's what it is right and so the main
character gets invited to this
prestigious one-of-a-kind fine dining
restaurant that's set on an island uh
and it's just like the most prestigious
menu that's ever going to be served uh
and weird [__] starts happening okay uh
they like you know how you know it's
fine dining is basically just the art
world but with food so it's it kind of
goes beyond just serving good food it's
all about the story of the food and so
you know you and at first the um the
chef comes out and he presents each dish
that has a different story behind it and
then the story just progressively gets
more and more [__] up until you kind
of slowly realize what's really going on
behind the scenes here and I'm not gonna
spoil what goes on behind the scenes but
let's just say the reviews are very good
as well yeah yeah okay it was it's
actually a genuinely good uh good good
story and I think this is okay this is
what I think is my personal way and the
best way to experience horror movies for
me is to not watch horror movies but to
watch YouTube summary of horror movies
I'm I'm that guy I think I watched
unfriended the same way the first time
yeah through YouTube videos I thought
there's no way to [__] to make it happen
yeah I mean I I watched all the Saw
movies just from all those videos of
like what's the possibility of Escaping
The Sword trap okay here okay so bad
before people clown on me let me let me
sell it to you okay I get to experience
the horror movie because one one of the
things one of the things I think is very
interesting about horror movies is the
mystery aspect okay every horror movie a
lot of I love horror movies even the
[__] ones they have like really
interesting Concepts that kind of like
draw you into like what's scary going on
behind the scenes you know so what's
what [__] up thing is this horror
movie about and 90 of them it's it's a
dumb twist or it's a or like once you
uncovered the mystery it's a dumb it's a
dumb mystery and you're like [__] I just
spent an hour and a half for a really
stupid feel so like the best way for me
to reveal uh to to consume it is just to
watch YouTube summaries which means I
don't have to be scared and I get
presented with a lot of interesting
ideas from all these different horror
movies and I don't have to wait an hour
and a half to uh to kind of like fully
realize if the reveal is worth it you
might as well just [__] read the
Wikipedia at that point you know what
maybe I will Joey maybe I will you just
should read the Wikipedia
DP page watch the trailer while reading
the synopsis there you go I don't know
why it's specific horror movies why I
just love watching stories of them
they're a throwback to the entire but
that hospital hentai was the horror
horror thing in in years I scared me
tomorrow I was scared yeah definitely
but a genuine horror movie that I did
enjoy that is a horror movie horror
movie is I believe the name is As Above
Down Below As Above So Below something
along the one in the French category the
one yeah the French categories yeah it
was yeah it was pretty good it's very
like Blair Witch is it like people get
lost in the catacombs and then saying
stuff okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah just
think blade witch but in the French
category yeah yeah they get they get
lost in the catacombs but things start
happening and uh they find out weird
things and there is a reason why all of
these things happen which is what I
liked about it is it it was less about
the jump scares but and it was more
about the unnerving ideas of what they
found in the catacombs you know um and
that's why I like French people
wasted
yeah there is nothing more terrified
been finding French people on the ground
honestly I I would uh I mean I would
just off myself at that point you know
just being stuck underground with French
people okay I'm done I'm done